welcome to this video this is a new part
of the tactics and calculation series
and I'm doing the tactics trainer again
here on chess calm I'm very thankful for
the many comments that I got for the
first video of the time because it
helped me to to adjust some settings
here one is that the board now is
considerably larger I think this helps a
bit with viewing they also turned down
the function that involves the timer and
I also don't yeah I use I do unrated
puzzles now so I can actually have time
to look at the positions and tell
something about them instant I'm not
pressed to play this each move
immediately to to to gain rating points
I adjusted the problems to be in a range
between 1500 and 1700 on the tactics
trainer at our infer the videos in
future videos I will adjust this to get
some something trickier and so on so
this will be 1500 to 1700 rated okay
let's start with the first position we
are going
we're playing YTM first thing that comes
to yeah comes to mind is that we have
very active pieces the queen is very
much near the king on a six don't you
know in the Kings on eight I cannot draw
any arrows here but you know we are near
the king we have a bishop on the long
diagonal which is a big feature
yeah bishop takes his six however he
covers c6 twice so that's not possible
we have rook coming over no Brooke b3
rook a3 this kind of moves might be in
the mix all of his active yeah rook b3
his god rook b8 and it's not a made on
b7
otherwise this would be good the next
thing that we should consider is what
about Bishop b6 you know this threatens
made on a7 and I really don't see how he
covers it
what has this intermediate checks on f4
but it's really just the check we can
just go King me one so Bishop d6
threatened
Queen is 7mate and there is no defense
to that that was pretty easy okay the
next one okay good black here we got
tons of pieces near the King let's looks
nice the knight on h4 the knight on d5
queen g4 or very active so on this
really looks like we should should have
something here the knight on h3 and the
rook on on f5
they both attacking f2 so I wonder what
does what about group takes what about
rook takes F - isn't this this just
possible just take this on F - after the
capture is going king edge one and then
just Queen takes g3 a threatening rook
takes H to mate and Queen g1 mate it's a
double threat he does not have any check
or intermediate move to deter me from
doing that so this is probably probably
sufficient and Queen takes after that we
threaten the maid on on g1 and the maid
on h2 and both defending both is tricky
and he has no check or whatever so we
just take this this probably was rated
1500 over 5 let's do the next one oh
this is Sam
this is actually an endgame interesting
so here we we have a basic end game we
are playing black yeah that's important
the board is switched so our pawn moves
moves ahead gem so what can we do we
have two basic possibilities we can
exchange rook and or we can't and if we
consider getting the rooks or keeping
rooks on the board like rook h1 check he
just plays king b2 and we don't make any
progress we need to check the exchange
first and okay
there is a video coming up on maybe
already released not quite sure on basic
kicking opponent games and if you've
seen that you will know that this is a
winning end game due to the fact that
black gets in front of the six ranked in
front of the power on the six rank and
and therefore we win the game we know we
promote the pawn you know this is a very
basic king opponent game the big point
is really and I can use this analysis
board know yeah I can put this and then
is this on the the big point is that we
get to one of those squares C 3 B 3 a 3
in front of the pawn which will help
black to promote the pawn after King B 3
we got the opposition and we will gain
even more space to get the pawn promoted
very basic component game okay the next
one okay here we are playing white and
you have the King here is really in in
bad shape and he has absolute has
absolutely no square to go to so on any
check is a major Queen f3 for instance
would be checkmate how do we how do we
manage to mate him yeah I don't see how
I get to f3 with the Queen I mean Queen
f1e will take and I made it I am I have
a hard time if I go with the Queen
somewhere else as always Queen f1 so
it's a bit tricky I definitely don't
want to trade Queens mm-hmm
so what do what I need to do is I need
to look at a checks the forcing moves if
I go somewhere with the queen is got
queen f1 so the thing is I can't play g4
check Knight takes check by the Queen
yeah and if he takes the Queen that's
not f6 checkmate this is the
the alternate possibility here why does
check meeting with Queenie 8th note that
he only has one defense Queen to g6 and
now Knight f6 is a checkmate that's very
cute yeah we can look at it briefly at
the with another spot unfortunately as
it is a separate board this is the the
big thing after this there is a check on
the fifth rank and if black takes this
Knight f6 mate this is a real point of
it yeah the the rationale here really in
the starting position is that white
really must do something dramatic now he
must give a check otherwise he's toast
if white is playing any move let's say
here then Queen f1 is coming and white
is made
so I need to do I need to only look at
HX in the initial position and and those
forceful moves okay the next one okay
we're playing you're playing white here
and we see that we have a huge attack
yeah Knight Bishop rupes
they are in the tech but how do we how
do we actually win the thing yeah we see
that we really want with to go with with
the rook on g1 pinning rook g1 would be
a pin on the bishop but he's got rook f7
and it's not clear how I'm going to make
any progress rook g1 rook f7 I don't
have rook age to g4 as the bishop is
covering g4 so we need to check the
forcing moves checks captures pins
things that threaten something and here
the capture on g7 is the right solution
because it wins the tempo basically BEC
must recapture and now we can give the
check Ian and this is deadly now king f7
why don't they do it on the same board
so if we look at this king f7 is rook h7
mate and like can only play stuff like
that to - yeah only get to a position
raise a piece down and completely lost
so it's a typical case where we need to
start with forcing moves in the starting
position which is basically here we
don't need to look at anything slow we
need to look at pins captures checks and
here the caption turns out to be the
right move order root G 1 root gap 7 is
not enough okay let's see the next one
no it's just not this does not look M
it's just an opening position right yeah
and what are we doing here he just
grabbed on e4 that's very greedy and
yeah we need to check first captures and
we already should look for something
substantial as we are much better
developed he has played a move like a 5
which did not develop anything yeah the
first move to check really is to take on
e4 the capture the most forcing move IAM
if we look at this and we only have two
lines black can take and now we have an
important thing in intermediate move
Knight takes f6
and rook T 190th we have one piece the
more interesting line in a way was the
beginning after the capture if black
recaptures there's a very important
motif that comes up time and time again
with with the uncounseled king queen a4
check double attacking the king with a
check and the nine only form the overall
grabbing those pawns opening up the
center is super dangerous anyway in this
case it's really a suicidal losing a
piece right away very typical is this
Queen a form of to pick up a piece that
has captured kept uniform okay let's go
to the next one
Computers calculating and move from
black yeah here we see white having a
big attack but how do we win we really
want to give checkmate on h7 the bishop
is on edge 7 when the Queen take ledge 7
would made him so we need to find the
Queen move to threaten the checkmate
black does not have any big counter
fight this should always be checked is
there some counter play checks does you
threaten to capture something with check
even but there's nothing Queeny for all
those moves don't make any sense so we
basically am can can look now without
being too worried about a counter attack
yeah how can we made a threat and made
on h7 that's Queen h4 Queen h5 between
h6 you are putting the Queen on the edge
file and yeah the move Queen h6 is the
most attractive because it's a double
attack we threaten the mate on the age 7
and they threaten the rook yeah the
company has this desperado move well I
take the Queen thank you
and now that's it yeah the big thing
about Queen h6 is that h7 is threatened
but the rook is also hanging so he
cannot if we look at the analysis board
briefly after King h8 Queen h6 he cannot
play f5 to break this diagonal because
this is a mate yeah it's a typical case
where you have couple of moves to select
from and the one that does the most
threatens the most doing a double attack
is the best one Queen h6 ok next one
let's see ok it's computing computing a
move and now it's it's blacks turn yeah
a funny position here we see that black
is a queen down for rook so we need to
do something now we cannot just shuffle
around and we see that White's King is
is in trouble yeah we have active rooks
and the Queen is offside on
six yeah how do we do that now we need
to look at checks checks are mandatory
here basically or what else is possible
sometimes is if we look at this the king
has very little squares there are mostly
two things being interesting here moves
that check him we are trying to get a
series of check in to checkmate white or
play some move that that takes away the
final square so that we can make him
next move
however whitey are threatening Queen
takes d3 so we cannot move from
something like king g6 or something what
we need to check first is checks and
this is mostly group six to d4 check
because look for to d4 let's the King
get away of to e3 so this check on d4 is
the first move that which you need to
look at and it's also the right one yeah
here we see that we really have them
close to a major it's very very close to
a mid we only need to get some checks
and two to finish him off but how do we
do that actually if we now consider the
checks again we have rook F for rook f3
or Luke g5 rook t5 he just goes back
which does not really help us that much
if we give on d4 check he goes back Luke
FY goes to e5 rook III he goes to d5 and
he might escape wire c6 so we should
check the moves that keep him in the
cage Ruka three check King e5 the only
response and again with a check we can
force a single response after Luke
effect each III check the only asking at
five and then after king f5 which is not
yet in the king ever does regret form it
so to show the final moves King a5 ruger
for mate yeah it's a case where we need
to check all checks first and make sure
that we
that we prevent the White King from
escaping versus the check check check
check mate okay the next one I see that
most problems are really more like 1500
and 1700 so maybe I am tune this up not
to get a little bit of variety in them
okay white to move we are attacking with
the Queen iya blacks king is open but we
need to be quick here we cannot really
waste any time
blacks be pawn is very threatening so
first things to look at is is checks the
queen or ever cannot checkmate alone and
the only piece that can help the Queen
now is the rook so it's probably
something that gets the rook to g1 near
the king and the key is that we first
make sure that we have the best possible
situation for that Queen f6 check
checking the checks first King g8 is the
next move and unfortunately it ends here
it really should have shouldn't have
ended because here there's King edge to
still to me to be played and now rook g1
check is deadly black has absolutely no
way to prevent that
white white wins it's a bit weird that
is it really not part of the puzzle
why not why isn't this part of the
puzzle the other the King edge to use
but okay it's it's clearly the way to
finish the absorb okay let's look at the
next one and claim black by displaying
c7 okay now it's again something where
we need to be quickly see part is about
to promote and we definitely want to
want to find the checkmate here
how do we do it yam the knight and the
Queen must be the pieces involved the
bishop on g7 it's just looking at its
own pawns it's just there to protect the
king
it must be night and queen who are
delivering them mate yeah what pew what
moves actually come into consideration I
actually think that maybe two moves come
into consideration first of all the
check on f4 because it's the the most
forcing continuation yeah checks are
always most forcing the second move that
might that might come into consideration
is something like pinning the bishop on
the second rank like Queen e2 or Queen
c2 and then get the night in but wide
will promote so it must be something
that really made slide I think we need
to look at the the night check first if
we give this check he can go to h2 to g3
so going up onto the side after both
move we have queen f1 threatening Queen
G to mate and there's no defense to that
so we need to check King g1 and King h1
King h1 we take on f3 was check and then
made on g2 and Knight f4 check King g1
we can take on f3 and we threaten the
mate on on g2 again and there is really
no defense you can go King f1 but then
we have quit h1 weather mate so it's all
about the most for signals Queen f3
threatening on g2 and unfortunately it
ends here but it shouldn't it should be
a little bit a little bit longer
actually while it's understandable that
we have a great position we still should
continue for a moment yeah King f1 how
do we win after this let me let me look
I see a mate in in three moves they're
made in Toulouse mm-hmm I don't see it
at the mode so let's let's play them the
main
in the made in to check limiting him to
Bishop Jiwon the only move queen g2
again limiting him to this one and this
is the mate maybe that wasn't made it to
but I'm I didn't see it it's all about
the most forcing moves especially if we
see that white is coming with big
counter threats that c8 and so on
okay the next problem okay first
computes a move for black yeah what
about this it's not equal for material
point of view of cod rook against two
pieces but the main point is blacks king
is totally open and again it's a case
where we need to look at checks and most
forcing moves we definitely don't want
to trade queens and what checks do we
need to look at Queen age a check he
will play King e7 now I can go to h4
with a check again and then you might
just go to d7 and it's escaping the
other check we need to look at is Queen
h6 check which quite similarly forces
him to go to e7 but now we have a key
move we don't need to check him all the
time it's not a median that we are after
but we have grouped g7 pinning the Queen
and we just doing the Queen that's
really really enough
the queen is enough okay let's do the
next one
okay computer hack computes black move
first yeah
and here we have a very very nice very
nice maid coming
it's it also has a name it's called
Anastasius mate
not quite sure how this name is Kay
where this name is originating but it's
a very nice very nice checkmate and it's
one of those cases once you have seen it
it comes to you rather naturally in a
position this is what I saw it
immediately and it's best to just show
it
why test this check King only has this
move and the defining thing of this mate
is this Knight here the knight on e7 one
if you want to have it have mirror
images on e 2 if it is white was getting
mated but this night it takes away the
g8 square the square that's identity and
yellow and this is the main point the g8
square is covered and the g6 squares
covered this is important because white
wins with the rook sacrifice and here we
can the roof is coming black can only
interpose a couple of pieces here and
then we got this very very CUTE mate
it's one of those mates
wait mates that stay with you if you
have seen it once then this motif will
be seen much quicker than when you have
never seen it before so a very nice
motif the defining thing being this
night only 7 which takes away g8n g6 in
this case Anastasius mate ok yeah again
we have a very dramatic position in
front of us blackest has just taken on
f3 and threatens to mate on edge to our
look is also attacked but on the other
hand we also have some substantial
substantial threats in the position what
we have here is mostly the G file and
the long diagonal so it's
or focused on the g-seven scam and in
situations like that we're all pieces
are pointing to one square or one and
peace upon we should check if we can do
something on exactly the square here all
is pointing at g7 and the move that
comes to mightiest Luke takes g7 with a
check let's put it on the board that's
the right one and yeah this is in fact
the toughest defense if black would have
taken we would have taken on f6 was
Czech and Queen g7 made next all pieces
point to g7 so that's where the critical
blow is delivered yeah but black simply
refuses to take if we now take on f6 he
can made us with Queen take H to look
bummer
don't want that so what is what is it
what we need to do here the the big
point is we can just prevent the mate
and set up a very strong threat we can
just play in this move which covers h2
and it is very nice now black has no
move with threatening Queen takes f6
with made soon to come he has no check
or anything available himself and Knight
e5 should maybe use this 95 is failing
due to the Queen hanging otherwise black
would have some sort of defense with the
long diagonal blocked but here is just
losing the Queen okay the next one and
it computes a move for black okay what
about this position yeah we see that
that's a rook endgame but it's not
really about knowing some elementary
endgame here the big point is the King
on e4 like has this advanced King which
is certainly in general an asset you
want active pieces in the book endgame
but here this also problem black does
not have any square for his King
besides the e3 Square and well
threatening to take the pawn so it means
that if we can prevent him from taking
and get a check and we will win and this
is such a case where when the simply
move like this with threaten Luke T for
mate and there is no way to get out of
this yeah this is a way to get out of
the mid but thank you very much I take
the rook very very nice just the rook
deform mate motif is important even it's
simplified positions it's very important
to look for mating ideas it's very very
surprising sometimes are often maids
occur in very simplified positions in
end games okay the next one okay
computers is computing a move okay what
about this position interesting hmm yeah
we have an active Queen and what also
comes to mind is we have two active
bishops it's a that's quite nice and the
week back rank is also an issue
what does not have have any any looked
for as king age three for example so how
do we how do we finish in mafia
interesting hmm
I don't see it right away
yeah the the whole the whole position
looks looks very shaky for white but how
do we actually win
it must be related to to all those
pieces being being pinned but how
exactly do we finish them off it must be
something with the diagonals the
diagonals here so the bishop is involved
so what we have here is a very weird
form of a cross pin what black can do
here is to play Bishop a6 it took me a
while to see that maybe not in good
shape but somehow I was always thinking
about the back rank
yeah Bishop a6 now after the capture we
can take on b1 and win the point is we
need to look at this again yeah this was
played and now Bishop a6 the the point
is that black is threatening a number of
things now he's threatening to take on
d3 of course take on and take on b1 if
white goes here the the big point is
that now we can capture and play this
and with this we will win the game we
attack the rook and give the check he
cannot interpose the only move that he
has is an ID one and then we take on d3
because Queen takes Queen txt one move
in the game so this was a bit trickier
at least I didn't see it right away and
what's very important if we go to them
Sudan them on the bigger board it's very
important to recognize here that there
are some very latent liabilities in
White's position the bishop is
protecting the rook the Queen the bishop
black is very active and there there is
something there's something there and
you need to really stay focused and try
to find it it took me a while really but
it must be something related to this
pieces or depending on each each other
yeah okay let's do one more and see how
way we had this we had us earlier so
this
this is not good let's do the next one
I cannot cannot just press next one so I
put this on the board again let's do one
one position again that I didn't have
before
okay here it's like to move and here we
see a very common tactical motif white
smooth and Knight c3 wasn't really
really good because now black can can
force checkmate and it's a very typical
thing that can happen if you have this
this pressure against f2 by Bishop and
Queen the big new phase Queen takes f2
can play that with a loud BAM and yeah
like white takes and now rook e1 mate
that's the point
we need a rook coming all the way down
to the background to deliver the
checkmate it's clear that is this yes
that white cannot yeah he went he went
here which was really really gifting
away a point that this cannot be
answered with King Ashwin as we just
take the rook so it's a very common
motif to have the combination of weak
back rank yeah the three points on the
second rank pressure on the F pawn here
and the rook ready to join the eggs only
one if instead here white could have
played some other move and nothing much
is happening Queen g3 for example just
cover the sensitive square on f2 okay I
hope you enjoyed the video this was
about problems with about 1,500 range I
actually set a range between 1500 and
1700 but it mostly gave me 1500 so next
one I'm going to to to tune this up a
bit to to to 1700 to type of problems I
hope you enjoyed it and yeah thanks for
watching till next time